hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to jontron bird vs. camel
now if you haven't seen jontron videos
or you haven't seen Schmo you hoes
recent collab with jontron where they
made a music video out of this videos
you're in for a treat check out the link
in the description or at the end of this
video in the annotations and you'll find
links to those videos there and you can
check out a lot of cool stuff now this
game was made in relation to the basic
video that's more homemade in relation
to Titanic but actually this was another
lyric in the game that was actually
related to a Star Wars game blot liar
get on with game alright so you got to
protect jontron from the camels you're
playing a jock and jock has lasers
shooting out of his eyes I tried it for
a little bit just to get a hang of the
game and it's actually really hard to
play with the controller because he's
goddamn stop spitting at me you douche
and these goddamn camels they just want
to spit all over the place
it would be easier with the controller
because I'm not used to met well
actually wait was it WASD okay I can do
WI see a little better than I can do the
other one cuz I can spam space a little
bit better but I have anyway I prefer
I've never played a fan game about
another youtuber before and I only
playing this one because I don't think
jontron ever would do a let's play of it
and I definitely wanted like tells the
world about okay
sorry that was my bad damn I lost a life
on the first wave I'm such a noob lord
scrublord so anyway you're trying to
protect jontron from these damn dirty
camels and you'll know what I'm talking
about if you've seen the Schmo kyoho
video or you've seen the Star Wars one
in relation to that one hello you didn't
know that I could come from behind this
2d world actually has a 3d aspect to it
actually is still 2d nevermind David yep
okay like I think the actual game they
were talking about was a Star Wars game
on the Atari where you were looped in
the in the in the fifth episode Wow
Jesus goddamn stop that Meccano Camel
Jesus I I'm trying to concentrate and
actually think what I'm supposed to be
talking about excuse me pardon me
ow [ __ ] yeah the Empire Strikes Back why
didn't I even think of that we're gonna
star wars fan of mine either way there
was a game on the Atari about this and
what kind of explaining a joke doesn't
make it any funnier than god damn Oh is
she okay sexy he's a little bit harder
than I thought I was gonna be
whoo all right you ain't gonna get to
nobody about whatever I got here did
ward did you do do them okay so this
game is a little harder than I thought
it was gonna be but jontron Joel all the
way over in the oh geez owns who built
these Meccano camels and why oh those
double oh god oh god oh god oh god oh
god
whoa okay okay
Oh boom I don't know what that
ex-marines but I'm gonna get you you
ain't gonna get to jontron I mean you
ain't going to get to jontron whoa what
the hell okay
god damn it oh no oh no I'm only I'll
win three I got one life left
I can't lose not lose for John I pop
okay ex guy I just got a word
Oh true scary too scary far too scary
you haven't ever been a bit of it like
everything in life this can be solved
with massive amounts of spam how about a
little bit of whoa oh [ __ ] this is bad
oh no oh god I thought that was gonna
kill me ah ah defeat jontron is now dead
I have failed to save him [ __ ] yeah we
fast forward to where I was before so
I'm not wasting anybody's time with my
suck
ooh at least anyone's time with my suck
wait no bring the music back
I played too long the music crapped out
okay there goes I thought it was gonna
be like this guy's sucks so bad we might
as well not play the music for him no I
suck so good
I've just got to stand walk into my wall
of laser death I'm shocked the game
can't even run Durell many bullets I'm
shooting
you oh you died before he could get out
of the gate
I truly am the best if I don't blow up
your butt oh I can go under him oh I
thought if I touch the ground it would
have been like death or something
it's weird do a little weird 3d 2d
platformer style don't choose at me you
[ __ ] Oh doubles up damn it
at least it only took one life there
don't know holy tits okay we're fine I
don't know why I haven't questioned this
up into this point
why why why camo lasers why Campbell
missiles what why is all this what is
happening I mean I perfectly understand
that Jacques is a robo bird but I'm
starting to question why these camels
are capable of shooting lasers out of
their mouths
you shall not pass oh [ __ ] oh god damn
it [ __ ] these things I hate these things
no you don't Oh God they're they're
fully orbital good thing I know I can go
around him this time
yeah but dubba dubba he's not really the
probe god double backpack missile guy
how's that not [ __ ] how is this not
[ __ ] okay okay gotta take out the
cop before he gets the jontron whoa
Wayne la whoa eh whoa whoa boy hey hey
there we go okay did I do it oh god that
was only rule those still only wave for
I'm or burn or wash yeah die die ah
don't die I mean me me don't die you die
me don't die he ever never never dammit
dude Oh nailed you to the wall jontron I
shall save thee oh I don't die I don't
die that's a lot it's got a lot harder
in the last few Oh tits it's got a lot
harder in the last few waves I don't
know why I'm still trying to talk and
play at the same time I just want to be
good oh okay my spam fingers ah they're
turning into honda oh [ __ ] I
I lost a life to those guys Otis if I
die here
I will bring shame to everyone come on
be the last one please yes yes yeah I
did it holy hell that was actually
pretty difficult I imagine it could have
been easier if I had oh did I get like
on the on the leader board oh I might
have gone lonely I think I got like 14th
plate there yay I did it okay
so this is an awesome game and jontron
he has an awesome channel he's an
awesome dude check out his videos if you
haven't seen them already you're in for
a day full of treats if you haven't seen
them already so check him out and also
check out that music video made by Schmo
yo and I'll put a link down is more yo
down the description below we might be
working together soon you never know so
thank you everybody so much for watching
check out the other cool videos down
there over there and as always I will
see you in the next video
thank you